- This week on 'Couch Tomatoes,'
we're talking HBO's 'Watchmen'
and giving you our Fresh
Picks on what to watch.
What's up guys I'm Naz Perez,
welcome back to 'Couch Tomatoes,'
sponsored by Freschetta Pizza.
This is a show where we
talk about the latest TV
and why you should tune in.
And today on the show we are diving deep
into HBO's 'Watchmen.'
I am so stoked 'cause
joining me on the coach today
is Shane Madej and Ryan Bergara
from Buzzfeed's 'Unsolved.'
Welcome back, welcome back.
- Happy to be here. (laughs)
- Again, happy to be back on the couch.
- I'm excited you guys are here
and the beautiful Roxy
Striar from Collider.
- Hi guys, happy to be
here from the first time.
- And you guys have seen Watchmen yeah?
- Yes we have.
- Yes.
- Oh for sure.
- Oh, for sure.
I joke because they are
major fans so I'm so stoked
to get into this with you guys.
So let's do this.
Set in present day three
decades after the release
after the graphic novel by Alan Moore,
which takes place in the 1980s.
The new series is already
getting a lot of praise
from critics and is
currently a Certified Fresh
with a 98% on the Tomatometer,
at the time of this recording.
Now guys Damon Lindelof, the
creator, has been very open
about the fact that this is not a remake
but a remixed continuation
of the 1986 comic.
But I know 'Watchmen' is very polarizing.
So I need to know, what
do people need to know
when they tune into this show?
Do they need to read the graphic novel
or have seen Zack Snyder's
film that came out in 2009
to know what's going on?
- Well this is much more
relevant to the novel,
as opposed to the movie.
We see things in episode
one, like the squid falling
from the sky that is
reminiscent of the novel
and the ending there, not the movie.
But I think that you
could go into this blind
if you really wanted to.
They are telling their own
story with new characters
and so it kind of depends
on how deep of a dive
you want to do beforehand.
But they're really trying to make it,
so that if you are a
new fan to 'Watchmen,'
that you can be a new fan
and still enjoy the series.
- Do you guys think the same thing?
Because I thought that at
first but then I was like
I don't know they're things
like 'The Watchmen's Son'
is the name of the play
that Jeremy Irons' character puts on.
I'm like, how would you know?
What do you guys think?
- I'm trying to put myself in the brain
of someone whose not familiar with it.
I feel like I would be overwhelmed.
I feel like people should
look at their calendar,
figure out how much free time they have.
If you're a busy person, watch the movie.
You'll sort of get it
without the very good ending of the squid.
If you have more time, read the novel.
It's so good and it's very readable.
It's not daunting.
- I will say in today's
age, though, to make someone
have a homework assignment
before they have
to enjoy this piece of work is a lot.
I actually think you can go into it blind.
I think it would help
obviously to have some
of the prior materials
but I do think it's very
watchable on its own.
- Right and I love that, watchable.
And if you guys go to HBO.com/Watchmen,
they created this Pdpedia
and they have a lot
of source material there
to go along with the show.
So I think that's kind of
an easy way to get into it.
- [Shane] I didn't even know it.
- But yeah, I want to get
into the controversies
of making the show.
But before I do I'm gonna
kick it back to a convo
I had with Roxy about the
best way to prep before
a big TV binge, check it out.
Roxy are you so excited
to be on the show today?
- Yes thank you so much for having me over
to watch some episodes
and just kind of relax.
- Relax?
You can't relax, we have to stay active
while we're watching TV.
- What do you mean active?
- You know active like
standing up to go get food,
walking all the way over to the kitchen
stretching to get that bomb food photo.
It's all exercise.
- Okay, that's the kind
of exercise I can actually
get behind.
- Okay good, because after our workouts,
I have a reward for us.
I made us this unreal
Freschetta brick oven
spinach and mushroom pizza.
The crust is so crunchy and amazing.
And they're all these
mushrooms and spinach on it,
which are basically superfoods.
- 100% and thank goodness for pizza
because who knew watching
TV was so much work?
- Listen it is a tough job
but someone's got to do it.
(both laugh)
All right guys so when the
'Watchmen' graphic novel came out
it was groundbreaking in many ways.
Mainly because it was reflection
of our deepest fears, right.
Like the Cold War was top
of mind, nuclear apocalypse
was still a threat and I feel
like this 'Watchmen' series
deals with some heavy issues
as well, mainly racism.
But in the same bold fashion
way that comic book does.
So why do you think Watchmen,
the series is so effective
at tackling these issues?
- I'll say that something about the sort
of alternative reality that they craft.
It's why science-fiction
works because you've created
this world that is not
totally recognizable.
There's something off in it.
So the stuff that's true or that reflects
our own society really
kind of, it really pops.
So I've heard people say
that it seems strange
that they're going with
the Tulsa Race Riots
and all this other stuff.
But the other series, the
comic did tackle Vietnam,
so they're handling real life issues.
- And I will preface
whatever I'm about to say
with I am a chucklehead.
So there's not a weight (laughs)
to what I'm about to say,
so take that with a grain of salt.
However, I will say I think
there's something about Watchmen
being a series where the
characters are looking inward
at their own morality,
which is, it's like this
introspective experience
which when it's against the
backdrop of all these fears
of the time, it kind of results
in people looking inward
at themselves when
they're viewing perhaps.
I don't know if that makes sense.
- No, it does make sense.
I think people, I mean the series opens
with a depiction of the
Tulsa Race Massacre right.
That's very powerful and when
it's told through Watchmen
or any sort of superhero story,
I think it gets people to pay attention.
I think that's powerful.
- I think that 'Watchmen''s
never been afraid
to take a big swing.
And that might work for some people,
that might not work for others.
But they are swinging right now
and they are saying,
we're not afraid to tackle
these massive issues in the same way
that the original graphic
novel was not afraid.
So it's a different issue
now that we are trying
to talk about but it's the same concept
that they are saying, okay,
we have a stance on this
and we're going to take that stance.
- Right, and I love the
stance that they're taking
because we never saw diverse superheros
in the Watchmen universe until now.
And now the fact that Regina
King is the face of it.
You know I think that's pretty incredible.
But I want to ask you guys
because I know you're superfans
and 'Watchmen' is so beloved 'cause
there could be this argument here right
that this could have
been a standalone series.
Alan Moore, the creator,
has been very open.
He doesn't like people
touching 'Watchmen.'
He doesn't like people adapting it.
He's not in the credits
of the show or the movie.
Do you agree with Moore?
Do you feel like 'Watchmen'
should be untouched?
Or do you like this continued adaptation?
- In my head his voice kind
of sounds like ra, ra, ra.
(everybody laughs)
- [Naz] He's like Scrooge.
- Kind of.
- [Shane] He's gonna come after you.
- I know.
- You guys would know the
next Buzzfeed's 'Unsolved.'
- I love him and I love Dave
Gibbons for what they created
because it was something that
was really impactful for me.
And it is his baby.
So I get why he wouldn't
want it to be touched
when he's not a part of it.
I really do get it.
I'm a creator and that's really
challenging for somebody.
That being said, if you
can't work on the art,
I still want the art to be worked on.
Because I still want to see more,
as somebody, pun intended,
I want to see "Moore."
Just not Alan Moore.
(Shane laughs)
As somebody who loves 'Watchmen,'
how does that grow today in 2019?
How do we move that story forward?
And just because he can't work on it,
doesn't mean there aren't
brilliant minds out there
like Damon Lindelof who can tackle it.
- Yeah, I was going to say
Lindelof of all people...
I know 'Watchmen,' even
before the movie came out.
There were versions of the
script that are horrible.
(laughs) They're not good.
And they eventually turned it into a movie
that a lot of people like, some
people have issues with it.
But having someone like Lindelof
who is a pretty thoughtful,
creative person, he's made a lot of shows
that really challenge people
and have a lot of new ideas.
So it's sort of an ideal
situation as far as.
- He's also pretty good
at handling universes
and world-building.
I think it's also just
like a curious question
to think about.
Like is the creator always the
best person to move a story
forward like you were saying?
Like we say that with
Lucas and 'Star Wars'
and even Stephen King having his issues
with the original 'Shining.' (laughs)
But it is a question,
I don't know if I have the answer to it.
I do think it's, I wish he
would be onboard (laughs)
as I guess what I will say to that.
- Yeah, but I love how,
I love what they're doing
without him and I agree with you.
Sometimes creators are
too close to the material
and Shane you brought
up the film 'Watchmen.'
64% on the Tomatometer.
- [Shane] That feels [right].
- 71% Audience Score,
Roxy I know you love it.
But has over a million audience reviews.
So I know a lot of people feel
some type of way about the film.
Personally, I love that
they made it because
I don't feel like one film can encapsulate
the magicness of 'Watchmen.'
And I think you need a series to do that.
- I think a series is a better
format to do that was well.
But I think that the movie
was true to the graphic novel,
which is why I liked
it and it's surprising
that Alan Moore does not,
because it's such a dead ringer.
I mean shot-for-shot most of the time.
Yes, we do have some
changes like the ending
where it's an explosion
as opposed to the squid
but they're, for the
most part, it's an homage
in the best kind of way.
So that's why it worked for me.
- Yeah, I love that you
brought up the ending
because I wanted to bring that back
to people maybe watching
this show right now.
Can we kind of explain
the squid storm Shane
that we were talking about before,
because if you watch the
movie, didn't read the comic,
you probably don't know what's
going on with the squids.
- [Shan] You're like why squids?
- [Naz] Yeah, exactly.
- [Ryan] Going to Squidtown.
- Yeah in the comic instead
of setting off some sort of,
it was like tied to Manhattan.
They set off this bomb.
In the comic they transport this squid
and make it look like an extraterrestrial
from another planet.
Like we're being invaded.
It lands in New York.
It's incredibly graphic and bloody.
(Ryan laughs)
- Yeah, which is why
there's a lot of predictions
that the squids now falling from the sky
is kind of a never forget
this is what can happen
based off the graphic novel not the movie.
- But is it a continuation of the hoax
or is this residual from the transporting
of I guess a giant squid that
was created by a biologist?
- See Ryan, I'm with you.
I feel like now the government's in on it.
But we'll get to theories in a second.
- I want to talk to you guys
about the standout performances
'cause whether you watched,
whether you read the novel,
watched the movie, you
like it or don't like it.
The standout performances are unreal.
We have three Oscar winners,
Regina King, Jeremy
Irons, Louis Gossett Jr.
So what have been your favorite moments
or performances so far?
- I love any time they cut
to Veidt and Jeremy Irons
because I have no idea
what's going on with him.
Which is similar to the
comic where for the first
two thirds of the comic, you're like,
well, what is the man doing?
- It's very strange.
He's like on his own little
'British Baking Show' island.
- (laughs) He's in Wales.
- And he's like reenacting
plays that he wrote.
And I was like, it's basically
like just a continuation
of his own ego which is very telling
of his character, right?
- He's incredible but
for me it is Regina King,
Regina King, Regina King.
She is so baller.
The way that she even rolls
onto beds, grabs the gun.
Like everything she
does she kicks butt in.
But she's also this beautiful,
wonderful family woman.
I just think that the way
that they're depicting her is perfect.
- I agree with you.
She's a perfect balance
of strength and warmth
and she makes me want
to be a nun in some way.
I'm like my mom would be so proud.
- This week when it was the
Christmas scene with her
and her husband and
she just switches from,
it was like just a really
wonderful tender scene.
And I was like this is great.
And then she just switches,
into like there's someone
in the house.
- Yeah and she's like
crawling in the kitchen
and going behind.
Yeah, so so good.
I really enjoyed Tim Blake
Nelson's performance.
- I was just about to say.
- Looking Glass I think is my new
favorite Watchmen superhero.
And that interrogation scene
in the pod was so sick.
He's so funny too.
- The second interrogation
scene, which I guess
isn't one but it is.
When he's talking to
Regina King in the car,
when he just speaks with
that almost robotic, even-keel voice.
It's pretty unsettling.
- And he's like that is how
I am crying under here or whatever.
It's so good.
But I agree with you guys: Jeremy Irons,
every time I'm watching I'm
like, what the f--k is going on?
And I have so many theories,
which is why I want to get
into theories but really
quick we don't know
the name of Jeremy Irons' character.
So is he definitely Ozymandias?
- He's Adrian Veidt, I think
- I think he is too.
- We think right, we don't know yet.
- There was a headline that
said, "Adrian Veidt is Dead,"
on one of the newspapers right.
He is for sure.
- Has to be.
- Without a doubt.
- And the purple and
yellow cake I was like,
okay this is him.
- If he's not him
why are they showing us
this man's birthday party
three different times?
Very weird choice.
- (laughs) His anniversary yeah.
- [Roxy] Or how does he
know to put on this play?
How does he know what happened?
- I feel like I would
not be utilizing you guys
to the best of my ability
discuss all the Easter Eggs
we've seen thus far.
- I will stay when "Unforgettable"
starting playing with--
- Don't put your fingers
together, what are you doing?
Yeah, we're going to do this
for each of our Easter Eggs.
- I'm talking like Steven Spielberg,
he does does every interview by doing this
and then he'll do that kind of stuff.
When "Unforgettable" started
playing when he was walking
around to get some more wine.
I was like, this guy's going
to get sniped in his own house.
Judd, who is who I'm talking about.
There was a palpable sense
of dread this entire episode.
When at any time he was alone, I was like
this guy's gonna die
and sure enough he died.
I'm not saying I'm a
prophet, but it happened.
- (laughs) I'm not
saying I'm Dr. Manhattan.
Well, why is "Unforgettable" an Easter Egg
though for people who haven't seen it?
- Oh in the film 'Watchmen,'
"Unforgettable" plays
when The Comedian gets murked.
- Yeah, most perfect use
of the song "Unforgettable"
by the way.
In opening of the film,
the one part I loved
about the movie. (laughs)
But "Unforgettable" is also
in the graphic novel, no?
It's played when Ozymandias'
Nostalgia perfume
commercials are on.
- [All Three] Oh!
- Come on guys!
- You got it.
- Yeah, I feel so fool right now.
- I forgot he had that
funny perfume commercial.
- What are some other Easter eggs?
- There are also a ton of owls.
Like through episode one and two,
there's an owl mug, there
are kids dressed as owls,
there's the homage to the ship in the sky.
All different owl references
based off of Night Owl,
the character from both the
movie and graphic novel.
- Right and there have been two Night Owls
in the universe just so everyone knows
and Hollis Mason, correct
was the first one.
- And Dan.
- Dan Dreiberg was the second one.
I thought Don Jonson's
character Judd Crawford,
not Judd Apatow (laughs).
- [Roxy] Was gonna be a third one?
- Is, I think he's Dan because
he had 'Under the Hood'
book on his desk.
- He did.
- Which is written by the first Night Owl.
- (whispers) Interesting.
- Do we know the whereabout
of Dan does it say on that--
- But he also was in Archie,
which is the name of the Owl ship.
So I'm like, is this Dan Dreiberg?
- Sup theory.
- Thanks guys.
- There's been a few also,
the ending of the pilot,
with the blood drip onto the--
- [Ryan] Classic.
- I can't believe that did not occur to me
that they would try to (laughs)
like put that visual cue
in there 'cause when it
happened I was like, whoa.
I got a little shiver when it happened.
- Why is it so profound to
people who haven't read?
- Because when The
Comedian dies in the movie
and in the comic book, he
falls out of the window.
- [Roxy] And there's a pin.
- I don't know if we can show it.
His pin falls off, no,
we'll leave it there.
- Alan Moore will hate us.
- He'll kill us.
- I already imitated him.
(Naz laughs)
I'm already on his crap list.
- So he wears that iconic
little smiley face pin.
It falls down out of the window after him
and a little drop of
blood just specks on it
and becomes sort of a visual
motif for the whole story.
- And this was on the
police badge was it not.
So that one drop of blood,
it was a little different
but a similar drop.
- And I think The Comedian
to the smiley face as a badge
not as a pin.
Apparently pins are not that badass.
- Blood drops in this universe
have a mind of their own.
(Naz laughs)
Very serendipitous the way they fall.
- What about the newsstand?
- That's interesting, I
wonder what they're getting at
and how they're gonna use
that to tell different stories
throughout the first season of this
or possibly only season I've heard.
- In the book it was always
just sort of a weird glimpse
into just the common folk.
'Cause they would just cut to
conversations between them.
- And then we showed the actually
comic that he was reading.
- Yeah the pirate comics,
which in this feels like
American Hero story is
like their embedded story.
So I hope we see more.
I was glad we saw more
of it in episode two.
I wonder if they're
going to continue that.
- Another, I don't know
if it's an Easter Egg
or a theory but I feel
like there a lot of twists
and turns in the graphic novel
and when we see that
Regina King's character
has been shot, the next thing that we see
is her in the hospital with somebody
who possibly could have
shot her if he is a bad guy.
- [Naz] Judd Crawford.
- Exactly, so there are a
lot of moments like that
in the movie and in the
novel where the next image
you see is actually the
answer to the question
you've been asking.
- Wow, that's a really good Easter Egg
and I think you're right
because when Angela
asks Judd, "Did everyone
or did you get shot too?"
I feel like he looks at his shoulder
and he's like, "Everyone got hurt."
He doesn't really answer
the question there.
- And he said everyone else died
except of us, so maybe he shot her
and for some reason has
a soft spot for her.
So brought her to the hospital.
- So let's get into that.
What are some theories and predictions
that you guys have for
this show moving forward
or flashbacks or characters
that you want to see?
- I'm super focused on Hooded
Justice and who that is
and what's happening.
In the second episode
with Muller, the woman
that we see who goes and
transcribes in English.
That last name is who Hollis
is referencing in the novel
could possibly be Hooded
Justice but maybe a relative
because it's a boy or is it Will?
I have so many theories
about who is under that hood.
- [Naz] A lot of people
think it's Will Reeves.
Do you guys think so because
he wears a lot of red
and the rope that's used
to hang Judd is similar
to the rope that he had?
- Possibly, I know that
we see in the TV show
that it's a white man under that hood
but that could be history.
- [Shane] That's also like
the TV show within the show.
- [Naz] 'American Hero Story.'
- It could be just some
whitewashing commentary.
- Yeah commentary on whitewashing.
- I thought it was like
the Black Freighter.
You know how the comic was within a comic.
- That's for sure what
they're doing with it.
- I think it could be Will.
I'll go out on a limb there.
I think it could be Will.
- What are some other
theories you guys have
or stuff that you'd like to see happen?
- I'm really curious
how they're gonna work
Dr. Manhattan into it because
they had that one little clip
of him just being on Mars
like tearing his castle,
his little palace down.
I was like, what's he up to?
- I think there's no way he's on Mars.
- He's back right?
- There's no way he's on
Mars because we've referenced
it 50 times, he's on Mars, he's on Mars.
If he was actually on
Mars why do we keep saying
he's on Mars?
- And you know what else
they reference a lot?
They say that he doesn't have the power
to shapeshift into someone else.
So it makes me think that maybe
Ozymandias or Jeremy Irons'
character, you know all
those clones he has?
Maybe Dr. Manhattan is his tinkering?
Because the castle kind
of looks like his house.
- Reenacting the whole
accident that turned him
into Dr. Manhattan, I wonder if that's,
yeah, it could be him.
Can you actually explain
that and go into that
for people who haven't
read the novel or the movie
and what that play was,
'The Watchmaker's Son.'
- So Veidt, if it is Veidt
who I said, Jeremy Irons'
character is reenacting
the initial accident
that created Dr. Manhattan
when we got caught
inside a testing chamber
and I don't know why
he's so obsessed with it.
- He's very method with recreating it.
- Yes he is.
- He sets a man on fire.
- His writing's so terrible
and he's like, I need real tears!
- I love when the other clone, he's like,
you'll be him now and
the guy was like, yeah.
Like I know, you're
gonna burn up tomorrow.
- Burn alive.
- That was so wild to watch
because as I'm watching
I'm thinking there is no way
he's actually burning a person.
These are great special effects
or he's got these robots.
He went there.
- [Ryan] And he opens the door
and the guy was Kentucky-fried.
He was definitely burnt to a crisp.
- Straight up, so they're
reenacting that scene
showing how he got to be.
Which is kind of great for
people who didn't read the novel
or who have never seen the movie
because now they know
what the origin story is.
- Also low stakes by the way.
I do love the moment of him,
me and Shane talked about this before.
That shot of Dr. Manhattan
just destroying his castle
like a kid playing with Tinker Toys.
It just cuts to this very ambient shot,
there's no noise.
It's just him knocking stuff down on Mars.
Like he's just bored up there.
- And for everyone
watching just so you know,
we've only see two episodes so far
and the other big thing that
we learned in the episode
last night was that Will
is Angela's grandfather.
So where do we think that
storyline's gonna go?
- I think it's difficult
because right now she,
people don't even know
that she's a police officer
and then they don't know
that she has this other
secret identity as well.
And now it's her family.
So she's already protecting
him before she knows
that it's her grandfather.
Now that she knows that,
she's not gonna turn him in.
And we don't even know if he is the one
who hung the Chief of Police even though
he asks her, do you think
I could lift 200 pounds?
So I think that she's, they're
gonna team up in some way.
- It was pretty obvious the hiding spot
that they found the cloak.
- Yeah, I wondered that.
- When they found Don Johnson's cloak.
- Yeah, Judd Crawford's,
I keep wanting to call him
Judd Apatow and in my head
I'm like Judd Crawford.
I don't know many Judds.
- I think that is not his.
- You think that it was placed there?
- No, I do not think that.
I think it's his father's.
- Oh, 'cause that picture, oh!
- I think a lot of this show
is about paying for sins
of your family members
and the older generations
and I think it's there
possibly as a reminder
to him as what his family has done
and how he has to fight against this.
Because it would just be too obvious
and too early of a reveal
to have him be that bad
of a person and there's
so many other questions
that would come up if that were really,
if he's really a member of the KKK.
If he really is this white
supremacist then why does
he live his life like this?
- Well the thing is he
has that painting up,
which is the title of episode two,
"Martial Feats of Comanche Horsemanship."
I'm curious to know how is
this White Night reference
going to be tied together,
Jeremy Irons' character rides
a white horse, there's a
white horse in the painting.
The White Night is another
name for the Tulsa Massacre.
How is this all going to play together?
- Speaking of which I'm
kinda curious how Rorschach
became the figurehead for
white supremacy in the show.
It feels accurate.
- [Naz] I kinda get it.
- [Ryan] I wonder if we're
gonna see any of that.
- Why is that accurate to
people who haven't watched
because he was ultra-violent in a way
or extremist in the comic.
- I guess that makes sense yeah.
- I think just because he was an extremist
and it seems like something
that someone would latch onto.
(laughs) They're certainly misinterpreting
a lot of his ideas but
he did send his diary
to the newspaper at the end of the comic.
- If Rorschach was alive
today, I don't think
he would be a member of this group.
I think based off of what he
stood for, people could read
what he was saying and
interpret it this way.
- Almost like a Rorschach blot.
- [Naz] Yeah. (laughs)
And if you guys actually
go on that Pdpedia
that was telling you about,
I think they explained
what happened in those 30 so years
and how that mask evolved.
You don't need to read it but
I hope that they explain this.
Yeah, it's like a PDF.
- Good to know.
- I hope that they
explain this in the show.
But I'm curious to know when
you guys read 'Watchmen'
graphic novel I feel like
everyone kind of sat around
their couch and they were like,
who do you relate to more?
And for a lot of people
it was Rorschach, right?
- I read it when I was in college
and I was like, yeah, he's cool.
But in retrospect as I've grown up.
I'm like that guy had
some issues. (laughs)
- Had some issues so how do
you feel about his iconic mask
now being the face of the 7th Calvary?
- When I read this there
was nobody that I was like,
I want to grow up to be like that person.
- [Shane] (laughs) They
all got some issues.
- I wanted to be Dr. Manhattan.
- Did you?
- Cold, emotionless.
- Just not wearing clothes.
- I mean that would be kind
of cool but so emotionless.
You don't want to be
sleeping with somebody
while you're working on your work outside.
- He has such a good memory in the comic,
he's like in 1959 I was doing this
and he's like on November
8th I was doing this.
I'm like that would be a
really great skill to have.
- Well, there were aspects
of each of the characters
that you kind of wanted,
except for some of them.
Like The Comedian I would
say outright probably
none of us wanted wanted
to be any part of.
- That guy we all agree.
- Weird sense of humor.
- I like the references to Rorschach
and people who are looking
at either the Minutemen
or the Watchmen and pulling
different traits from them
and that's the start for this series.
- What are some other
shows on TV that you think
people should check out if
you they're into 'Watchmen'?
So shows like 'Watchmen.'
- I think you're into
'Watchmen' a show that I love
that people have not been really talking
about is 'Doom Patrol.'
Now, it's a DC property.
So if you like 'Watchmen,'
it's a comic book property
by DC and it's weird.
So in that aspect it's
kind of similar because
it's very offbeat like
squid falling from the sky,
that kind of stuff happens on the show
all of the time.
And it's also got that hero
aspect where the heroes
are not the best people on the planet.
They definitely have more
layers to their onions
and like I said it's off, it's strange.
It's on DC Universe and if you
want to be part of something
that seems really weird but also kick butt
then 'Doom Patrol' is where it's at.
- I'm sold.
Shane what about you?
- I'd go with 'Leftovers,'
which is Damon Lindelof's show before.
It was also HBO.
Roxy you were saying you were a fan.
- [Roxy] Massive, massive love that show.
- It's incredible.
I think it's very handy for
people watching Watchmen
because you sort of get a feel
for how he approaches stories
'cause he always comes at
stuff from a weird angle.
- Flashbacks as well.
- So many flashbacks.
He sort of took everything
he learned from Lost,
I know a lot of people have
some beefs with that show,
I love it and improved upon them.
And when I heard he was
doing 'Watchmen,' I was like,
yeah, perfect.
- And I think I've heard
through the rumor mill,
that 'Leftovers,' you
know how certain episodes
focus on one character?
I heard that that's what's coming up
or what we should look forward
to for 'Watchmen,' yeah.
What about you Ry?
- I would say, I guess
not in the sense of tone
because the show I'm about
to suggest is not as strange
as weird in 'Watchmen' is but
in terms of dystopian future,
I would say, 'Man in the High Castle.'
That's basically the
entire premise of that show
is this alternate set of
futures and if you're into that
sort of thing, it's a fun show.
- I would say, check out 'The Boys.'
'Cause I love seeing superheros
in this raw real human
way which is why I love Watchmen
and I think 'The Boys' does
that and season two comes out
Summer 2020, so you have
time to catch up on it.
So as major fans we can
obviously go on about 'Watchmen'
all day, every day.
Are you guys going to stick with it?
Do you like where the
story's going so far?
- Yeah, I'll watch it
until, as long as it's on
I'm gonna watch it.
I love Damon Lindelof, I love 'Watchmen.'
I'm here.
(Naz laughs)
I'll be here to talk about
it whenever you want.
- Yeah, I think I'll stick with it.
I have a TV.
So as long as I have a TV I'll watch it.
- 100% I'm a Watchwoman now.
This is definitely going to
be a show that I stay with
no matter what even if
there are highs and lows
because I feel like they
know what they're doing.
They have and endgame
and I gotta get there.
- Yeah, I'm so excited to see what happens
because I heard that the
series gets so so good.
But now it is time for our Fresh Picks.
These are shows, doesn't
have to do with 'Watchmen,'
just any show on TV that
you think people should
add to their watch list.
What are you guys watchin'?
- 'On Becoming A God in Central Florida'!
If you've never heard of
that then you're not alone.
Because nobody knows what that show is.
- [Naz] It's on Showtime, yes?
- Yes, it's on Showtime,
it's Kirsten Dunst.
It's weird, it is a pyramid-scheme show.
And you're watching it all happen
screaming at the television,
like, "Don't do it!"
Every single episode, I
can't believe this is getting
more buzz right now because it's awesome.
It's really great.
- Do you think it's
because it's on Showtime?
Maybe it's had for people to find?
- I don't know, there's
so much content now.
There's so many TV shows
that I think this might
be like 'Succession'
in season two more people
are going to catch on to it
if we get there, hopefully
enough people watch that we do.
But if you are interested
in it, you'll know
off the first episode if you like it.
The way the first episode
ends you're either
in or your out.
I think the first episode
is for free on YouTube too.
- From the YouTube king himself.
(all laugh)
- Shared crown.
- Kings.
- YTK.
(Ryan laughs)
- Sorry Ryan was OG.
Ryan's like gonna kill me. (laughs)
Shane, what's your Fresh Pick?
- I would go with, it just
ended, 'Righteous Gemstones.'
I heard a lot of people talking about it.
I'm not always sold on
Danny McBride's stuff.
So I approached it with caution.
It's got the usual
incredibly vulgar vibe to it.
But it really ended up surprising me.
I wasn't totally sold from episode one
but by the end of the season
it lands in a place that's
surprisingly heartwarming.
It's weird, it's the most
vulgar, insane, heartwarming
show I've ever watched.
- Is it funny?
- It is very funny.
Also there's a woman on
it named Edi Patterson,
who I haven't seen in anything else.
I think she wrote for SNL
and was on 'Vice Principals'
but she is so funny.
- [Naz] So good in that.
- Check it out, you've sold me.
- (shrugs) It's what I'm here to do.
- There is a part of me that wants
to say Great 'British
Baking Show' just because
of Jeremy Irons' birthday cake island.
But,
(Naz laughs)
I will say, I'm just gonna
say 'The Good Place.'
Everyone knows 'The Good Place' is great.
It's the last season,
you can watch it live.
Not a lot of great shows are
actually live on television,
where you can watch it
and it becomes an event.
Get it while it's hot.
- That's true, I like that.
- I'm watching 'Living With Yourself.'
Have you guys seen that
with Paul Rudd on Netflix?
Paul Rudd playing Paul Rudd
and opposite Paul Rudd.
- [Ryan] Oh yeah, I
saw that on a bus stop.
- Yeah, it's really good.
It's very easy to watch.
The episodes are like 25 minutes long.
There's only episodes,
there's a great cliffhanger
at the end for season two.
And Paul Rudd's just so likable and funny
and there's a Tom Brady
cameo that's a little
controversial right now
but that's all I can say.
But it's definitely a reason to tune in.
- You know what? I've got
my finger on the pulse
of sports so well that when
I watched that first episode
he showed up, I was
like, oh who's this guy?
(Naz laughs)
And then in the next
episode they mentioned
it was Tom Brady.
I was like, no idea who that was.
- You are sitting next
to a Bostonian right now.
My heart hurts, my heart hurts.
You didn't know Tom Brady.
You sat me next to someone
who doesn't know Tom Brady.
- Is the twist there's a third Paul Rudd?
- Well, you'll have to, this
is a no spoiler show Ryan.
So I can't disclose that information.
- Yeah triple Rudd.
- Whew, at the thought of it.
- I don't think I can handle
that I love him so much.
All right guys well that is our show.
I couldn't have done it
without unmasked vigilantes,
Roxy, Shane and Ryan.
Thank you guys so much for
joining me on the couch today.
And for more on Watchmen head
on over to RottenTomatoes.com.
Also please comment below and
let us know what you think
about the series so far.
We love reading your theories.
Also don't forget to hit
that subscribe button
and notification bell,
so you don't miss any future episodes.
Join us next time as we talk
about at 'The Mandalorian'
on Disney+, so stoked.
I'm Naz Perez and I'll
see you guys next time.
(upbeat music)